elles arrivent tour à Tours
sont de la difficulté à se frayer un
chemin jusqu'aux urgences de l'hôpital
Pierre Le Gardeur à Terrebonne
souvent c'est des personnes qui vont pas
bien c'est des temps difficiles pour nos
urgences à la audience ça semble être
complètement plaît c'est des civières un
petit peu partout dans les corridors
dans ces corridors loin des caméras il y
a une femme atteinte de sclérose en
plaques qui attend depuis plus de 24
heures couché sur un petit banc en
douleur une autre qui s'est fait dire
qu'en raison de son niveau de priorité
elle devait attendre plus de 20 heures
c'est à ça que ça ressemble une urgence
occupée à plus de 200%. les personnes
qui viennent qui sont couchées dans nos
séances sont vraiment mal ils ont
vraiment besoin de nos soins et la
situation est loin d'être unique à
Terrebonne un peu partout au Québec
l'histoire se répète depuis des semaines
maintenant les urgences débordent et
manquent de personnel une fois qu'on
dépasse 150% tout devient très
dysfonctionnel on obtient les ambulances
on peut prendre jusqu'à 20 minutes juste
pour trouver une civière un patient il y
a énormément de Québécois qui viennent
sonner à nos portes qui repartent en
bord de médecins c'est justement ce qui
est arrivé en fin de semaine à un
septuagénaire qui a attendu 16 heures à
l'urgence sans voir le médecin le
lendemain il s'est rendu à un autre
hôpital il serait décédé des suites d'un
anévrisme un cas abandonné par le
système selon certains médecins loin
d'être unique environ 40% des patients
qui traînent sans avoir vu un médecin
selon le docteur boucher
dans d'autres hôpitaux ici ils voient
l'infirmière de triage font un ou deux
tests ne peuvent pas voir de médecins
équipe puis on les voit 24 heures plus
tard puis oui ils ont eu une crise
cardiaque oui ils ont eu des infections
de manquer des choses qui arrivent c'est
malheureux le triage c'est pas fait
c'est pas une manière de traiter les
gens le triage d'une manière de
prioriser les gens c'est ceux qu'on va
prioriser mais un moment donné c'est la
priorité de la priorité de la priorité
là c'est elle qui paie le prix au bout
de la au bout de la ligne elle ce sont
les infirmières au triage sous pression
parfois en nombre insuffisants et face à
des choix déchirants alors que les
heures d'attentes ne font que s'allonger
ici Jacques Audry Charbonneau
Radio-Canada Terrebonne